and practical jokers fans we are finally
on the road again doing a tour 40 cities
up right now tons more if you don't see
your city get them at impractical
jokerslive.com uh we just added a second
show in Portland we had a third show in
Boston and a second show in St Louis and
we also added Banger Maine where I've
never been look forward to it this
weekend Niagara Falls on Thursday Newark
New Jersey a Prudential Center on Friday
the 10th Wallingford Connecticut on the
11th Big Show at the UBS Arena home of
the New York Islanders on March 12th
following that we got Green Bay we got
Milwaukee we got Rosemont we are also
doing meet and greets we never do them
but we're doing doing them online right
now what you got to do is the new season
of Impractical Jokers is on at 10 pm
every single Thursday on True TV and now
on TBS take a picture of yourself
watching it hashtag at Joker's watch
party upload it to your socials and
that's it you get tickets and a meet and
greet to shows we're getting a lot of
winners
um so that's the only we don't sell them
you can't get a meet and greet that's
the only way to do it so watch new
episodes of jokers and I hope to see you
and meet you and greet you in
practicaljokerslive.com
taste buddies mark your calendars May
10th will be the first ever live
streaming taste buds episode you asked
for it we're doing it you're gonna be
able to watch live in real time there's
going to be surprises special guests
it's May 10th more information to follow
next week on how and when and where to
get tickets I will tell you this it will
also be live to premiere of the footage
of Joe's punishment dresses Ronald
McDonald tending bar so there's going to
be all sorts of fun stuff like that May
10th taste buddies it's going to be one
to remember
to them uh actually this coming weekend
I'm going down to Baton Rouge Lafayette
and New Orleans one show in each City
and then I'm off to South by Southwest
from there gonna be doing the I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden Show in all
these places also at South by Southwest
I'll be doing my sandwich Summit where I
talk with other sandwich shop owners a
couple Comics coming in to have a good
time and make things funny all that is
happening over the next week come out
and see me uh after that this month
later on I'm gonna be doing Rose Garden
again in uh the crane theater in New
York City on March 22nd and then after
that I'm going out to the Midwest
Chicago second show just added uh and a
bunch of other cities out that way go to
jodarosainfo.com for all information and
ticket links and then if you're in New
York come to Joey Rose's Joey Rose's NYC
for all your information they are open
seven days a week thanks folks they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two Foods gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to them Tasties welcome
to
t-a-s-t-e buds we're back have we ever
hey baby have we ever called them
Tasties yeah I did once and you really
liked it yeah but then we kind of
tapered on Tasties that's funny that's
funny she's good uh it's good to see you
it's good to be back
um I want to address right off the bat
the way I'm sitting
yeah I
I in the last two videos yeah yeah
I'm sitting this way because in the last
two videos I said this to you before we
started I I had I had arrived the last
summer recorded and people were saying
dude you dropped some weight you look
good I was like thanks I told you that
myself I was feeling good thank you
thank you and then I saw myself in those
videos it looked like Brendan Frazier in
the whale I mean it was crazy it was I
don't know what was going on you looked
like an award winner an award winner yes
uh you know my chin was so the double
chin was so pronounced it was so bad
people I don't know how it looks in this
video I won't know how it looks until
after I think you looked pretty
distinguished I love the I love that
sweater you're wearing thank you very
much yeah I love the texture of it I
like it a lot that's what it suits you
thank you it was on its way out
and you found your life with it yeah it
was on its way out because a you've had
it too long B you don't like the fit or
the feel C
there is no C
uh I at times don't like to fit at times
I like the fit why was it on its way out
though take up too much space in the
drawers like I you know what it was when
we started doing the Joey Rose's pop-up
I was wearing the sweater a lot to go up
to the stand I'll just check it because
it might be principal
let's not principal yet all right we'll
get to that okay uh uh I was wearing
this a lot to go up to the stand to work
on the pop-up
and it was such it was an exciting time
because we were doing that but it was
also getting rid of it because it's
emotionally attached to a time period
this is what I'm gonna say not kidding
it was such a dark period because even
though we were doing this cool thing it
was locked down yeah it was not a happy
time you have attached that to this I
wore it so much during lockdown that I
just was like I don't know man I think
maybe I don't like this sweater anymore
and then I was like No wait it's an all
right sweater it's got some legs still
in it yeah it's nice Now's the Time too
when Winter's on the way out I like it
yeah but anyway anywho
it's tough getting on camera every
single week it is especially in 8k and
you know people love to just know I feel
like we are I feel like we're up yeah
you got 10K at Best Buy no they don't
you got 10K Best Buy with people it
doesn't matter if you buy it they're not
gonna have the technology for the TV but
they're how about they still don't have
a great K Best Buy if you're watching
and we know that you are what are you
doing to us we we we've our best price
for well we believed it we're not making
a TV why are they pushing this product
are they telling you are they telling
you that it's Best Buy does a
salesperson telling you that you're not
gonna get 8K I hit a Best Buy I had a
Best Buy sales person say look it's a
great TV but it's you know the the K
doesn't really it's not relevant because
you're not they can't stream or produce
media in that K not even eight TVs are
out K in the case right right it's too
much case but it's you know it's
ridiculous and though you can see every
little blemen and people are mean people
are outright mean I learned and I can't
remember the name of the of the code
that was instated but it was it was
through the government United States
government but when I studied
telecommunications when I was in college
I actually learned that they were able
to move into high def technology as
early as the 60s
the government stepped in and put a
pause on it and they made they
implemented this thing where there had
to be a time period that lapsed before
they were allowed to explore it fully
and interesting I remember myself once
now it was right when high def was
starting to become a thing okay late 90s
yeah and my teacher was like
the the gloves are off now they're like
there is this this like stipulation
thing is gone so Watch What Happens and
he was right right it's like look how
quickly we're jumping through the the
the definition of picture at this point
it's insane also 4K rained down on us
rain blows down upon us I mean my
Blu-rays I'm taking unwrapped Blu-rays
off the shelf and replace them with new
4k that's crazy nuts just 4K Blu-rays
now it's 4K 4K DVDs now 4K is a is a
form of Blu-ray but it's 4K you want to
get this you ready for this I am this is
the sickness I've got stuff on my shelf
that's 4K transfer and uh my buddy Pat
Walsh you know Patty Walsh yeah shout
out Patty Walsh he was like dude I'm
replacing my criterions with the 4ks do
you want my old ones and I go I go what
are you talking about I have those
they're the 4K transfers and he goes
exactly but they're not real 4K oh now
I'm getting real 4K discs so the four
key transfer first there was 2K
transfers before that yeah then you know
who they're going for you guys only
specifically yeah I will tell you this I
got a handful of 4ks true four case yeah
it's no joke I understand it looks real
good at what point can our eye not
process the difference between 4K and AK
are we gonna watch AK and be like 4K
what's up remember 4K it was like we
weren't is it was that [__] I thought
that when I saw a DVD
yeah but you know it's freaky AI now I
can take your home video footage and
upscale it to 4K through the AI for free
well no you'll probably end up paying
for it who's doing that who who this is
AI who do you know that who do that I
can also like AI repair audio and have
your grandfather's voice AI like fill in
the dead air getting Goosebumps bro
we're in a bad way dude I don't like it
it's not good I don't like it I'm
getting sent an article every day and
not just for my mother anymore right I'm
getting sent an article from Friends
peers and colleagues and now it's
populated in my feed and I'm just
getting anxiety riddled I mean we got
you can't fix my double chin pimp I mean
all of a sudden he's Mr [__] wizard
over here where were you last week
what's the budget
I mean it's just not ai's got to become
our friend right no one's just saying
that though what about if you become
best friends with AI there's got to be
benefits somebody's marrying this thing
yeah it's it's friends with Benny's
I've just never said friends of Benny's
in my entire life and I never will again
how about that I hated wait you're
talking to AI I have chat EBT opened and
I asked it about the top 10 fast food
like you could do anything with these
what's Chad gbt it's an AI oh babe get
with the progue
get with the ram babe get with the ram
this thing is sweeping the niche
AI out there that can have full-blown
conversations this is sick we already I
already did I put uh Casey Joe's text me
because the writers were like uh write
us uh in Impractical Jokers bit and it
tries it does it like but it wasn't good
or anything and then then they were
sending me screen shots and we did it
hey babe uh write a joke in the in the
voice of Sal vulcano and we did write a
joke in the voice of of Joe DeRosa you
did yeah Casey sent it to me oh it's a
joke tell me yeah yeah I love it
uh somebody right now let's see if it
does the same one all right wanna do it
right now um
let's see if it does the same joke Casey
sent me oh wait
did Casey send me this he I I can't
imagine I might have been on the text
and not it's fully just Blade Runner
this is real bad guys oh wait we glazed
over see we talking so much about the
robots we glazed over the human element
of my double chin story okay
my mom
my mom told me at dinner that it looked
fine because I saw the clip where we
were sitting at dinner
and she said I look fine she then called
me later laughing and said your father
and I think you look like Kim Jong-un
see your own family did you dirty like
that I saw that in the comments isn't
that rough yeah by the way the fans the
fans
I don't know why I [__] read them I
haven't never read in a long time and I
just was like they really did not like
your haircut I know so opinionated on a
haircut there was a lot of opinions
about the haircut this haircut in my
opinion is a banger
I said it too when I saw you a couple
weeks ago I was like he was one of the
thank you yeah they came they went down
but why do people care so much about how
you decide to style your hair why I
think people just why not watch the show
take what you need from it and that's it
why why spit the vitriol
I've never understood the compelling I I
criticize and I complain but I do it in
my own little Forum I don't ever go to
somebody else's thing right and go this
sucks about you that's crazy Sebastian
has a really funny joke where he's like
he's ripping into Yelp and people that
want and he's like we don't go home and
tattle on the restaurant yeah yeah he's
like I took to my wife and I say salmon
suck let's get the [__] out of here yeah
yeah that's a great
joke's pretty uh oh actually I want to
do a joke
uh in Sebastian's voice and see if it
does that yeah what is my joke uh women
say they want a man with good sense of
humor but let me tell you something
ladies when I pull out my collection of
fart jokes on our first date suddenly
that sense of humor isn't so sexy
anymore
that's a fail I mean it's not a good
joke it made that no the jokes are not
good it gave me a hack one when he did
it it was like um what was that freaking
hack joke they did before it was
literally like
oh yeah like like I went to that doctor
all right I gotta uh you know he told me
I I told him I can't stop masturbating
he's like well can you at least stop for
now not that [__] that's a stock
joke stock that's a that's a that's a
yeah my doctor said I have to stop
masturbating I said why doc he said
because I'm trying to examine we're in
the office yeah exactly yeah yeah it
gave me that so now it's like completely
suspect yeah yeah but that's not even
Casey you sent me a joke a street joke
he wrote today I thought it was so funny
check this out
a store manager runs over to a security
guard and says officer someone is going
around the mall coming on everyone's
jewelry the security guard says not on
my watch
[Laughter]
I thought it was great I was like that
is a great joke that's very funny that's
very funny wait so let's oh this can I
tell you the other thing my mom said to
me I'm here for this this is what I'm
here for we talked about at dinner
two two major insults two made for my
own parents
my dad came up with the Kim Jong-un how
well do you know your parents I thought
I did okay not well at all all right uh
wait we're dinner we're talking about
did he laugh at his own joke he was
laughing I could hear him laughing in
the background she was telling it to me
that you look like yeah that's so funny
it was very hurtful uh
[Music]
they uh day at dinner we're sitting at
dinner and we were talking about
I won't name the celebrity only because
I want to absolutely make sure that it
doesn't in any way sell like I'm I'm
making light of this but we were talking
about a celebrity that is dealing with a
certain malady
uh that's very unfortunate and I said uh
I said how much I admired this person
because of their spirit I was like it's
amazing I go you look at somebody like
that you think oh what a Charmed Life
and then they get hit with this terrible
thing and they're still out there
putting their best foot forward I was
like that's amazing that's amazing I go
I don't know how I would deal with
something like that if it got dealt to
me and my mom goes you wouldn't you
wouldn't do well
[Laughter]
and not joking she was very serious she
was like you wouldn't you wouldn't
handle it yeah wow I mean Frank Frank
Frank Frank yeah but I mean just
throwing bows at me dude I mean Stallone
right there Frank Stallone
uh wait so wait this is stuff fans said
well fans and friends I should that's
the question you guys a little younger
you know Frank Stallone is
he's the other Stallone oh do you know
who he is no ever heard of him I thought
it was Jerry Stiller's name in Seinfeld
that's Frank Costanza okay okay Frank
Stallone is is is Sylvester Stallone's
brother who resembles him didn't have
the career as him and at one point was a
singer all right listen let me give you
this stuff real quick I got some of this
too I didn't I only brought yours
Hornswoggle a woman a woman you're with
she tells you it comes out after a while
that you're about to be intimate she
tells you she has three boobs like in
Total Recall
your gut instinct is it excitement or is
it like I don't know if I want to see
the three boobs on one chest it would uh
it's it's figuring out how to not flee
immediately on foot okay got you yeah
there's no there's no excitement there
for the extra boob no it's here okay in
fact we're battling Seinfeld versus
friends today yes uh pimp reference
Seinfeld one of my favorite French jokes
is Chandler uh uh Courtney Monica goes
she's giving Chandler food and chicken
she made she goes I've got three breasts
a leg and a thigh and he goes how do you
find clothes
[Laughter]
yeah it's a very funny joke anyway uh
this is from wait do you stick around
for the boo what do you stick around for
the boom part of me is curious okay I'm
not sure if I'm excited
I had to see because it's a little more
of a good thing or is it something you
can't get past it's a question for the
ages really it's something is it such a
thing as too much of a good thing
also there's got to be all new tricks
remembering uh remember I don't know
there's an extra hand in there they're
playing screens and Automobiles yeah the
first 4K that I bought and I know the
line you're gonna say right yeah you
know what I was you know I went I went
to put that on yesterday
swear to God I didn't watch it during
the holiday season which is like I never
you got to get the new 4k release
because it's got It's got all this extra
footage on it that's never actually
footage I like but I will say one thing
I want to see Planes Trains in the way
that I used to watch it it does I like
it not being in 4k would it but but let
me be clear like a movie like that in 4k
there's only so much you could do
it's not that it looks like weirdly new
did you guys know this movie Jeff
yeah of course V oh that's my girl
coming through it just looks like you're
watching it like in the theater for the
first time okay it looks like it still
has the texture okay it just looks now
have you ever been disappointed by a 4K
where you
that one is actually the most
disappointing of all the 4ks I've bought
picture wise but at the same time I
would never you it's very hard movie to
notice
you don't need 4K for that movie where
you watch Total Recall like this the
footage on Mars you're like holy [__]
this looks so cool like
those aren't pillows that's such a funny
joke yeah you play with your balls a lot
that's a great time to get salty they do
a great time together oh they that's
really the like the first time ever I
see it today Duke you're right candy
does it perfect yeah all right you play
with your boss yeah
the shower curtain rings as earrings
he's like these are filled with they are
they're very light yeah dude there's a
scene a deleted thing
on the 4K
I'm not I'm not exaggerating dude it is
a 15 minute scene of when they meet on
the plane for the first time that is
completely cut from the movie
oh it is a candy the first time that we
think he sees him is in the opening
scene getting into it no no that's all
the same I'm just saying when they first
sit down next to each other on the
airplane
and candy starts talking to him and then
and then Steve Martin goes no offense
I'm not much of a talker yeah yeah and
uh and Candy goes last thing I want to
be known as a blabbery you know whatever
he goes to that real fast in the movie
okay there is a 15 minutes of John Candy
you're just rambling dude he's just
going on and he's going what's your name
Neil is that Gaelic I I think it's
Gaelic right it's just like just like
like literally like offensively boring
right dude it's so funny yeah there's a
deleted scene where they get a meal on
the plane V do you know who John Candy
is
my heart V come on my heart stop Uncle
Buck V stop it
Summer Rental The Great Outdoors Great
Indoors angry grate out to us well I'm
gonna be angry yeah
alone
um yeah he's in the home alone at the
end oh sure he's the Kenosha kickers
yeah he uh there's yeah you know he is
okay there's your deleted where they get
a meal on the plane and John Eddie
starts talking about like yeah
is like meal strategy for each Airline
at least describing all the different
meals it goes on that uh on that on that
flight I'll get the kids meal a little
hot dog Oreo cookies and a juice box
very tasty
I had a friend once she worked in a
kitchen for an airline
lapped off the top of her finger
it's so if I could bring if it's so much
hypothetical like bring a one person
back dude
as far as a comedian oh my God John
Candy dude it's like died in his early
40s I think he was like 41. yeah that
was back when 41 looked 41. yeah you
know oh man he's he's a he is the
[__] ultimate and I feel like we got
if you step back and really look at the
whole thing we got a lot of John Candy
we got so little of like
what we needed to get yeah like you got
Uncle Buck
one of my favorite movies of all yeah
same as well
um
and then like after that it's like
there's there's like there's like John
like like the great out I know and I'd
say Great Outdoors would be the third
one when I was a kid I love summer
rental but if you watch it now it's uh
it doesn't have a lot of jokes yeah but
uh but even like like I like armed and
dangerous because I'm a fan of it from
when I was a kid but it's not a good
movie you know what I mean yeah but I
could name three jokes from that movie
that I like immediately from already in
the English which is let's say
somebody's lying right and you know
they're lying can you shoot them
that's a great job state your name state
your name my favorite candy moment in
the movie is when the girls cats in the
tree yeah and she goes please she's
crying please climb up there again and
he goes
[Laughter]
he played uh Del Griffith in Planes
Trains he played it so good he's amazing
like that that
he was annoying and endearing at the
same exact time until he pushed it too
much but then he reeled you back in
because he was he had heart in it it was
like he walked this line this character
and when I found out spoiler alert when
I found out that he didn't have a home
yeah it and there's a comedy really
foremost I cried ever at the end of it
hit me like a ton of bricks we just had
him piecing it together yeah see more
and piecing it together we just did
we'll and we'll see you in hell we just
did top five movies that make you cry
every time you watch them yeah we each
picked five and honorable mention was
Planes Trains because we've talked about
it so much I was like we can't do this
one we've already done it yeah yeah but
it like we've talked to the length about
like I cannot get through my friend chip
once said he goes if you watch the
internet his name's chip yes because
he's 50 years old first name Charles
birthday oh it's Chip short for Charles
yeah I didn't know that's all I met him
he's the only chip I've ever met my
uncle's name is Skip I found out like
like five years ago his real name was
Vincent
but he was saying he goes you're not a
human he goes he goes if you watch the
end of that movie and you don't cry
you're not a human being like yeah right
but by the way there's stuff in the
deleted footage
that actually elaborates a little bit on
why Steve Martin doesn't trust him that
much okay
there's a scene that you see of the wife
at home where she's complaining to her
mother about how he's never home Steve
Martin okay
yeah and like so that that's why there's
a lot so much when he gets home I'm
reading about all this yeah but uh
but there's you got you if you get that
that 4K you got you got about I would
argue 25 minutes of unseen that I would
buy just for that any more candy I can
get uh there's a scene in Uncle Buck
where he's uh the neighbor the nosy
neighbor who's played by uh the girl
from Roseanne wonderful actor Laurie
Metcalf Laurie who I saw on Broadway
doing misery with Bruce Willis I saw her
on Broadway
Beach Memoirs oh wow how was misery how
was Bruce Willis in misery
no shade right
I would she like really out I felt like
in a live form she she outclassified he
might have been he he you might say he
was like understated but she was a
lunatic you know she she really was like
wow how did they do the thing at the end
when they fight and everything like do
they do that on Broadway uh it was
really cool actually that it was uh the
house was on like a lazy Susan almost
like a you know and and it would turn
and and as they walked into the other
room and so they had multiple houses
like you know their bedroom and all that
stuff but uh yeah Misery the other night
I love that's one of my favorite movies
dude it's arguably the greatest Stephen
King adaptation ever I mean it's amazing
she's Kathy Bates if that's on I watch
it she's a she is amazing she's
legitimately scary I've seen it a
hundred times I'm still scared of her I
still feel like anxious when she thinks
she's when he when he drops the freaking
thing off and he faces it the wrong way
dude she that's one of the scariest
movie villains in a horror movie it's a
horror movie yeah essentially either way
right it's like a thriller but she's in
like top have you seen
no that I've never seen come on guys get
your [__] together but I get your head
out of [__] ai's ass
and go watch something
not nothing hold holds up you'll be you
will love watch it right away you'll
love it dude when she get to know your
top five crying movies how are you not
gonna tell us oh uh I'll tell you it was
uh it was and like we had to name the
scenes in each but I'm gonna just rattle
them off uh it was uh grumpy old man
Malcolm X
uh
uh Empire Strikes Back
Superman and um
the fifth one was um
The Untouchables when Sean Connery dies
wow those were not the movies I would
think you would say I just I picked ones
for different reasons but the legitimate
I started I said Pat and I I'm not
kidding on the episode Pat and I both
started crying talking about the movies
are you serious I'm dead serious he
talked about the Royal Tenon bombs like
when when the sun when Ben Stiller says
at the end of Gene Hackman I've had a
hard year oh my God I'm sorry before
it's it's I want I want to be part of
this but Prince Paul's asking if you can
come so yes
I just finished up can head over to you
how long will you be there I just want
to make sure I can make it on time
this is wild you know I've been
listening to this guy since I was 11
years old
where do I tell him I got two copies of
his album because it went out of print I
was scared I wouldn't find it the one I
had would get damaged
oh my God you love data you just
collected data yeah
no Paul start Pat started crying on the
episode talking about the end of real
tannenbaums had to at one point turn
this camera off and walk off and clean
himself up
and then I started crying when I this
episode is sponsored by better help we
appreciate them uh we talk about uh
better help uh a lot on this podcast
they're a big sponsor I uh I gotta tell
you if you have never tried therapy you
were thinking about it I think this is a
an accessible
really good way to try it I I used to
live with anxiety still do but I never
really realized that I didn't have to
live
and just deal with all the anxieties I
had
um I just and not get better with them
and and when I started doing therapy
really really changed my life so when
they came on as a sponsor we checked it
out and we really really liked it
um if you've benefited from therapy uh
before and you should try this too
because it's completely different
um it's entirely online uh it's designed
to be convenient and flexible uh to fit
your schedule especially in this day and
age uh you don't have to make any
appearances you don't need to be on
camera actually uh just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist you could switch
therapists anytime at no additional
charge and I think that is a really big
selling point because a lot of times
when you go to therapy in person just
like anything else you have to click
with the person in order for it to be as
maximized you know potential of it and
uh it's hard it's hard to start out
regular therapy and then then quit that
person and find another person this
makes it way way easier so discover your
your potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com taste buds today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com taste buds funny
joke yeah all right guys if you're
trying to do something about your
overall health and we all are you know
that there are fad diets that come and
go and maybe you were successful on some
of them and then boom as soon as you
stop them the weight comes back that's
why you have to change your lifestyle
and Noom is not a fad it uses psychology
not Trends to help keep your your your
your your your intentional sustainable
choices and they are aligned with your
weight loss goals uh it's true it's like
you have to stop and you have to think
like I have food triggers that I didn't
realize right so I now when with using
noon which by the way 18 pounds 18
pounds I've been using NuMe and one
other thing which I can't mention but
I'm really I will now not put myself in
situations that lead to me falling apart
I avoid situations it's all psychology
based all right new empowers you to
build more sustainable habits and
behaviors basically the program helps
you understand the science behind your
reading choices and why you have
cravings everyone's journey is different
so your daily lessons are personalized
to you and your goals and whatever your
health goals are the flexible program
focuses on progress instead of
perfection not going to beat you up if
you have an off day right choose your
level of support from five minute daily
check-ins to personal coaching first
time nooners lose an average of 15
pounds after being active in the program
for 16 weeks and 95 percent of customers
say Noom is a good long-term solution
stop chasing hell Trends and build
sustainable healthy habits with noon
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com slash
tastebud that's n-o-m.com tastebud to
sign up for your trial today check out
news first ever book the new mindset a
deep dive into the psychology of
behavior change available to buy now
wherever books are sold
and then I started crying when I started
talking about Empire Strikes Back At
what point it's when he goes it it just
destroys Star Wars meant so much to me
as a kid and I saw that I saw Empire
Strikes Back in the theater it was the
most the most excited I ever was to see
a movie was Return of the Jedi because
of how bad Empire Strikes Back [__] me
up with the Cliffhanger ending and
everything but I was like seeing Han
Solo uh in Peril like they're gonna
[__] do this right now they're gonna
freeze this guy and they're like what
the [__] and so it starts with that
and uh God damn it it's gonna make me
cry he's getting there it's uh
when Chewbacca starts uh throwing the
Storm Troopers out and you and you're
like oh my God he loves him
he really loves him
I am crying I am crying I like shoot
ings
at least he's texting Prince Paul he
just you just stepped on my emotion I
mean I was oh my God I'm so sorry you
literally have tears in your eyes I'm
sorry I was I was like my ADHD was going
okay and this was over Chewbacca's in
this
that was serious yeah and you're like oh
my God because up till that point
Chewbacca is just this like big
rough like dog thing you like them but
he's not like tender and you're like oh
my God he loves him and then and then
the Capper is I love you and he goes I
know to to Leia you're like holy shitty
finally he does love her yeah yeah uh
and then and then the [__] dude that
ending with him still frozen
it like I I didn't even I couldn't even
compute it as a kid I couldn't do you
know I didn't understand I was like this
doesn't make sense they lost you know
what viscerally shook me as a kid sure
you mentioned Superman I I want to say
it's Superman three
okay oh when he turns evil no which one
is that [__] me which one is this
three zod's two two is two is that the
one where he gets beat up in the diner
yep and roll and [__] me up threw him
into the Jukebox and he's bleeding he
rolls and the guy beats the [__] I mean
he beats him up later yeah but like when
he throws the guy into the Jukebox but
the guy beats him up and he like he just
put he just like puts him down on his
knees basically well before he got back
at him when I watched that yeah I was
like I was so like moved I was like so
upset so one of my honorable mentions on
the episode was
was Superman too
when he comes back and he's Superman
again and he goes uh
I was the best thing ever
oh my God is that 30 yet yeah where are
we at 30. okay because I know this
friend's time is Big okay yeah when he
goes uh when he goes uh care to step
outside Zod I I you're you it's you're
it's so awesome yeah yeah yeah I know
but I feel like I got to think of a
movie that I cry with now
like I said I cry literally at
everything Pete offender repeat crime
yeah I could give you songs immediately
but
um crying in a movie
I mean I can't think of anything but if
you just write a list I'd be like yes
yes yes yes yes yes
as a kid I remember crying at the
Terms of Endearment
Kramer versus Kramer made me cry beaches
but these are these are what I'm a kid
you know like a young classic uh those
are some gear jerkers
I didn't classic Star Wars
um
simply Bambi
she gets lit up anything anything
like truly heroic
yeah where you see like people come
together Jay Big Jake remember Big Jake
cried it uh
[__] Vince Ben Affleck and Bruce
Willis
Armageddon yeah
dude all right we gotta get to the
battle let me give you these gifts
really quick I got texted the joke of
the joke in the style of Joe DeRosa hey
how's it going
so I was at a restaurant the other day
and I ordered a steak and the waiter
asked me how would you like a steak
cooked and I said oh just cook it until
it's still bleeding but it's not
screaming anymore
and the waiter just looked at me like I
was a psychopath and I was like what
that's how I like my steak
but then the waiter came back and said
I'm sorry sir we can't cook your steak
that way we only have medium rare or
well done and I said well in that case
just give me the medium rare and tell it
to stop being such a wimp
I gotta tell you to tell you closer to
you than the other one I gotta tell you
it does
King a big deal out of nothing yeah in a
restaurant thing
when you just said the masturbating the
one we did the other day they put me at
the doctor too
so I went to the doctor the other day
and he said I had a vitamin D deficiency
and I said doc I'm from Staten Island we
get enough D out there
he just looked at me and said I don't
think that's the same thing but hey what
does he know I feel great
did they just say I take penis I don't
know I don't understand what that means
but dude they got you Staten Island down
oh I think that's what's insulting it's
referencing personal data about you
somehow
well I mean I'd imagine right
it scours Wikipedia you know whatever
scours the internet so it can collect
certain pieces of information I mean
this is bad but everybody keep playing
with it like it's nothing
it's still learning that's what's scary
that's what's scary it only referenced
Staten Island now for sale because it's
still learning
watch Megan man Megan like really
depicts it very well do you like that I
didn't get to see it yeah it was good
but it depicts like the evolution of of
AI I don't need any more anxiety anyway
all right look we gotta get to the
battle do you want me to give you these
now or next episode next episode let's
get to the battle
sorry Horn squaggle uh t-shirt in there
you close that box just because my uh my
OCD
can you kick it to the right please I
just don't want to even see it to the
right not forward but now it's right in
my line of sight well don't look at it
it's impossible you don't understand OCD
I would just like it out of my purview
please
just just with my original ask
if you can just get it
thank you I'm back
please clip that
[Laughter]
now I'm telling you right now I think I
think in people's opinion we got a bit
softer here all right we're too calm
it's too nice I've been crying we got to
get salted all right all right all right
yeah yeah
ready yeah
who's going first you insult me first
you go first because I need to know what
your level is
uh
all right ready yeah it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
grow up with the shoes grow up wow
you're 45 years old you're running
around like [__] Punky Brewster
that's enough shout out Punk it's enough
it's enough oh wow see I thought these
would I thought these were it's enough
hot like fire as the kids it's enough
you know shoes don't make a personality
you know what I mean oh really yeah well
I have enough to go around on the person
uh pimp do you like him
I love them I love them
love them and obsessed okay one of these
guys is doing his own thing keeps
wearing a shirt that was sewn together
from two different shirts
[Applause]
all right and V didn't know who John
Candy was so I you know I don't know
where you're going for your support here
to get approval from clothing-wise
because I just feel like he wears just
just different I I feel like he just
wears different textiles all right like
his whole entire thing is just take a
little of this a little of that this is
a shirt but I'm gonna wear it as a pants
I know I hear you yeah all right hit me
back ready yeah
grow up you just told tens of thousands
of people that you cried over a goddamn
wookie
and you cried in front of him right you
cried in front of him over Chewbacca
yeah it's a kids it's I cried when Han
Solo died in force awakens with
Chewbacca and he just told you told me
to grow up with my shoes right you can't
tell me this is at least it's just at
least fashion you agree with it you
don't you just said to me the irony grow
up with the shoes when you were wiping
away the tear that was still there for
crying over no emotions about an age
limit okay I didn't know emotions at an
age limit I mean I mean I don't know
crying at Chewbacca though why I mean do
you wear underooses you guys don't even
know what on the roost is there was no
laugh yeah no no no you guys know what
underuser
Underoos for the [__] actually if I had
they still had on the roots I'd get them
I know they were great yeah you know
what I love color forms color forms but
underuser close no I know but I would
play with colorful what about freezy
freakies bro I don't know what that is
what do you what do you what do you I
don't know what it is it's the gloves
that when it got cold the things would
appear on them
it was literally like you couldn't get
them when you're younger
it was like a Cabbage Patch oh yeah oh I
remember those yeah oh wow right I
forgot that existence all right how
about this they I thought of it like
three four years ago and we were going
on a ski trip and uh with Ari and a
bunch of comics whoever everybody was
there and uh I was like let me see if
these I was gonna buy us old ones they
re they re brought the company back and
I bought brand new freezy freakies for
everybody
what the hell all right we gotta get to
the battle Yeah
we got friends versus Seinfeld I am
taking friends
because well Cassell per usual ghost I I
have to take the easy win I didn't do
that I have to take I didn't do that at
all as a matter of fact you called me up
and you go babe I got it Frasier versus
Seinfeld yeah
during the show last week you could hit
cream we've talked about on the show and
we were just about to do Frasier
Seinfeld and I was like
versus curb right which would have been
that's that's well friends is really a
behemoth as well so I last time we were
on I said I can't do friends I have to
do Fraser Fraser is my arguably my
favorites to come of all time so is
Seinfeld arguably sure
what
here's the thing V said friends is great
uh I found myself for some reason
curious after she said friends is great
I never watched it I've been watching
friends for the last two weeks she's
shocked that you don't watch Friends now
into not knowing the last 10 references
we've said well she was here twice
here's why I didn't watch friends
friends came out when I was about a
senior in high school
uh you know senior year you're not
sitting home watching sick every girl I
knew though it was only watched at that
time and I and I know I watched Friends
and friends was friends was big enough
to it was it overcame so it was senior
year then I went into college and you
know it's party time you know and then I
started doing stand-up it was like I
just saw dinner until 98
. Seinfeld came out when I was like 90.
freshman in high school or something
yeah uh and I by the way I never watched
Seinfeld when it was on I re I'd seen it
but I Revisited it uh you you didn't
want I never wanted until it was over I
watched the finale because it was such a
big event
and I hated it I hate it I enjoyed the
finale I still don't like the finale I
like the finale and it put me off of
wanting to see any more wow that's crazy
and then about seven years ago I was
addicted 70 years ago or so I called
shout out Pat Walsh once again and I
said is Seinfeld worth buying because
it's like 50 bucks for the whole series
on Amazon today and he was like you're
insane buy it right now oh my God and I
bought it and I watched it all the way
through and then obsessively ever since
and I was like this is probably the
greatest sitcom of all time but I used
to deliver pizza and I got out at 11 but
if there was no there was no orders I
could mop and clean up and get out at
about 10 45 and I lived like seven
minutes from the Pizzeria and I would
mop and clean this is a syndicated
Seinfeld at 11 PM just to get home fast
enough to hit record on my VHS and I
have my own Seinfeld VHS Library there's
about five six episodes per tape and I
had a marble notebook with the episodes
and the guide in the notebook that's how
much I love signing yeah no I I hear you
I should do that with the Twilight Zone
yeah before I owned the whole thing but
uh the uh you sorry I love Seinfeld
I did the same thing with Frasier I went
back after the fact and fell in love
with it I love Frasier so much friends
in all seriousness as of this moment of
the recording of This podcast friends is
not even in my top
probably 10 sitcoms of all time because
I am less familiar with it than the
others however but given that V piqued
my curiosity yeah and I started to watch
over the last two weeks I am falling in
love with it and I if you watch from the
beginning yeah and I've gleaned enough
now because I will obsess watching
sitcoms from the beginning is tough you
got to get to like season three of any
sitcom before I actually think season
three of friends is where it starts to
get a little I I don't think that season
is anywhere near as good as one and two
oh really so far and then and it bums me
out because you can start to see
you can start to see in season three
that they're becoming that they're
famous now yeah they start to look
better it's like the thing Rob mcelhaney
said about when he got fat for It's
Always Sunny he's like they just start
to look better and better yeah and
you're like oh Jennifer Aniston like I
can tell like she was in this movie by
then and like whatever I'll tell you so
I thought what I thought you were gonna
say which is one of my criticisms of
Seinfeld if I'm being fair was that
if you watch the first season like it's
a tough watch it Finds Its stride in
like this might be an episode or a
moment halfway through season two is
where side all that stuff right yeah
it's the washing machine when they go
down for the washing machine Revenge
yeah and Kramer does the whole set piece
with trying to pour the cement in yeah
and that might also be the nose job one
if season two is that the tape the tape
machine the phone what's that answering
machine one whether it goes that's two
or three I don't remember but yeah but
that's when it that's that that that
that whole yeah I'll tell you what
Seinfeld suffer from I thought that it
became so
the most popular thing on Earth that
that they then started
the story lines came from a place of oh
we have a formula now like and then they
the the character you have to I guess
evolve somehow and the characters became
caricatures it was so it became a
cartoon the last two two seasons are
like a cartoon maybe even three seasons
they're doing it's almost like they
hired new writers and the writers were
like let me let me write a Seinfeld
episode from what I know the last two
seasons have some of the best episodes
and by far the worst episodes like like
but like there's not nowhere near like
two through six there's some bangers in
the last two seasons yeah for sure but
but overall it's very very by the way
the misses I still love like I'm just
saying in comparison to themselves but
Seinfeld you know I mean I'll tell you
what Seinfeld and friends have a lot of
the same traits as a sitcom you could
put it on and like it could be halfway
through one and you literally watch it
because it's instantly it instantly
grabs you for the last two weeks I've
been watching friends at lunch and
anytime want your dinner at home I watch
it
anytime I'm working at home I have it on
the background and then I've been going
to sleep to it so I'm I'm I'm pretty
deep into season five four at this point
okay I've gone through a lot oh this is
what I do I get obsessed with you don't
even know that you're about you don't
know about what happens in like the mid
to later Seasons I know how the show
ends I've seen the finale why
why why that you're you're shocked that
he doesn't know the end of the show yeah
well
yeah they go through
I watch like the opposite Seinfeld which
made a problem with it and kept it I
know that Ross I know that Ross and and
uh uh Rachel eventually break up I know
that Ross is going to get married to the
English woman I know that Rachel comes
back in I know that Chandler and Monica
end up together I know the series ends
with Monica and Chandler with the babies
and them leaving and this is what I will
say I know all that because I've seen
some of it out of sequence over the
years and like I'm putting it together a
lot of like a lot of tumultuous things
yeah no I know I know yeah
um and some of it I don't know but you
know dude this is where I'm at I was
online last night it was online last
night looking up Phoebe's apartment I
was like where does she live do we say
it ever I want to see now I want to see
what Phoebe's apartment looks like
that's weird that she doesn't live there
too
uh anyway so um she uh anyway I will
tell you this right now and I'll say it
right off the bat
as far as Landing sticks go Seinfeld
doesn't hold a [__] candle as far as
I'm concerned to friends I already know
sticking the landing I will be crying my
eyes out at the end of friends the way I
do at the end of Golden Girls when they
on that house at the end of golden girl
I'm like it is devastating sure and
that's what the end of this will be I
will tell you that Seinfeld Lacks
that kind of emotion but that is not
they build their show
promising you you will not get emotion
it will not be relationships that you
have to latch on to they will not they
said that that was as advertised and
they stayed the course and they were
like I don't even mean the show about
nothing because it is about stuff but
it's just like they just stayed in
self-contained episodes for the most
part and they stick stuck to their
formula it was about jokes it was about
shitty people it was that's not what I'm
talking about I am not talking about the
emotional depth of something okay I know
I said that it's it probably sound like
that's what I meant what I meant was
and this is why I can argue friends over
Seinfeld friends I do think the
emotional Resonance of friends carries a
lot farther than the character
characters of Seinfeld because of the
emotional depth but
it's a show that that hinges on the
friendship and the relationship of those
characters and it lands in a place that
you feel fulfilled where those what you
saw those characters Seinfeld did not in
any in my opinion anyway shape or form
deliver a fulfilling well resolution
they become so unlikable in the last
episode they are such Petty people and
they do try to do a little [__]
emotional thing when the planes going
down Jerry I always wanted to oh give me
a [__] break it was just a little bro
that was a tease and then they didn't do
it it's lame it's a breadcrumbs
they have at hand right you have you
have a history of these six characters
in their relationships in their
friendships that had an arc over all
those Seasons so when you're wrapping it
up you have a lot more invested to wrap
up Seinfeld State a la carte it stayed
it stayed to just we're shitty people
and so you're not gonna get that kind of
gravity but here's thing too here's the
thing too I don't agree that Seinfeld
was about
shitty people because it wasn't it was
about people being frivolous and and
Petty you know what sums it up nuanced
what sums it up the one where Elaine
gets the number the other the Bizarro
friends sure Feldman from across the
hall yeah when she tells Jerry she can't
hang out with them anymore the way she
describes their Hangouts that was later
on though I know but she says she goes I
can't keep coming to this apartment
pouring over every little stupid thing
about life or whatever
that to me is what the show was about it
was a people that had absolute purpose
yeah but but it's minut but here's the
thing by the end of Seinfeld yeah
they're they don't even care about each
other anymore it's there's there's a
camaraderie with Seinfeld in the contest
the the the pinky you know the pinky bet
whatever how they should do it they have
it they're a team and they get each
other's backs and they help each other
through their problems and they fight
and whatever they're real friends now
it's not emotional uh in the traditional
sense but they are friends
and then it gets to a point where it's
just like oh now like he does like he'll
he'll like throw George under the bus
even like like I said it I thought I
thought it did unravel the last couple
of Seasons but I think that what it did
right and what it did for so many years
was so good that it's forgivable and I I
don't think those last couple of seasons
are knocking its position out of first
place I think most people collectively
think Seinfeld's number one and I think
that's held the test of time Seinfeld
has been off the air for 25 years at
this point 25 years and people still are
like this is the best sitcom ever people
don't still say that about Mash people
don't still I mean they're old they
associate about friends right but that
was kind of at the same time I know
that's why I think he's a good adversary
yeah but I mean and I'll tell you what
friends you can't even knock it because
they did get into the Zeitgeist and it
did influence a lot of things it
influenced fashion it influenced uh
people the way they spoke but nothing
more I can't you can't name a thing it
is people speak in Seinfeld quotes
not even quoting Seinfeld people use
Seinfeld quotes to communicate in their
regular daily dialogue they do that
that's a that's something that is who
else has achieved that there were there
were friends things that they did with
that I remember I remember but but also
too I'll say this about you want to
throw the Zeitgeist you look at the
guest star list
see that episode yet
all right well when you do everybody's
half asleep or eating a steak you know
what it is
not absorbing every detail
do you guys want to guess which one had
the bigger finale wait wait hold yes I
do what years I know it was Seinfeld oh
four oh it went six years past Seinfeld
94-04 wow I know that I know that
Seinfeld had the bigger finale the Time
Square watch it was crazy
how about that I don't remember what I
was for friends the type of show that it
was my neighborhood bar hello fresh
hello fresh hello fresh with hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it's America's
number one meal kit let's talk a little
about help with hellofresh okay with
hellofresh you're getting seasonal
ingredients picked at Peak ripeness for
Quality you can taste ingredients travel
from the farm to your home in less than
seven days so you know it's fresh they
make it easy to eat what you love
customize select Meals by swapping out
proteins or sides even adding protein to
a veggie dish and now you can upgrade
for organic chicken or organic ground
beef on select meals okay
sure we love hellofresh here I mean I
got hooked on it when they sent it to me
to try at first and now I can't wait for
those brown bags to hit the mail and I
get them and I know that week I'm having
something that I haven't had in a while
but the cost of groceries going up now
is the perfect time to get started with
hellofresh it is 25 less expensive than
take out and cheaper than the grocery
store
go to hellofresh.com tastebuds 6-0 and
use the code
tastebuds60 for 60 off plus free
shipping again that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds60 use the code tastebuds60 for
60 off plus free shipping
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
94-04 wow I know that for instance I
Know That Seinfeld had the bigger finale
the Time Square watch it was crazy
how about that I don't remember where I
was with friends the type of show that
it was my neighborhood bar the type of
show that Seinfeld was the fact that it
was as basil is is nuts yeah this is
like an it's like a niche little weird
like just found something we're gonna
shut that window I am freezing you could
absolutely shut up I just I just wanted
a blast of fresh
here's my point though what I was gonna
say you want to talk about Zeitgeist put
that phone down I'm just talking about
we got v on it let V do her job you do
yours right here right here okay right
here right here
uh
we uh of course I just reached into the
cookie jaw no no no no I didn't mean to
slap you that hard then I started
laughing it was too hard it was fun the
um you went through with the Zeitgeist
dude look up guests guest stars on
friends yeah I'm not impressed Brad Pitt
I'm not impressed it is nuts they were
all A-list celebrities and she was
married to Brad Pitt wasn't she I I I I
I switherspoon
she couldn't believe she got to go in
yeah and be on friends like I know uh
Matthew Perry got to date Julie Roberts
yeah because he's faxed her and said we
want you to be on the show it was fun to
see those people but what Seinfeld did
is the opposite Seinfeld broke people
broke people before they they hit it
like I mean literally stocks what
Courtney Cox what about her she's
episode of Seinfeld oh sure yeah the
fake wife yeah absolutely uh uh but Cox
but also Brian Cranston Tim Watley you
know what I mean and the list probably
goes I would I would argue though I
would argue I don't think Seinfeld broke
people I think they had a lot of people
on there before no that were talented
but like Brian Cranston was broke by
Malcolm in the middle much more so than
Seinfeld Courtney Cox obviously was
broke by friends not by not by Seinfeld
so on and so forth but but I will say
Seinfeld has a lot of people where you
go holy like you know Pat and oswalt's
on an episode of Seinfeld sure
um but John favreau's on an episode
outside and friends yeah favreau's got
one fabulous fabros favros era Eric the
clown right
yeah
he's my favorite Seinfeld uh Cameo is
that right is yeah when he goes when he
goes that was before he was known at all
and he goes why are you giving me a hard
time
man yeah
it was just a game
yeah it's short the clown put it out
with his big shoe
um that was before he was anything then
he was on Friends actually after that
but I'll tell you the nothing nothing
has
dug its claws into the Lexicon of
American Pop Culture The Way That
Seinfeld I'll even say go to movies go
even beyond that I I think that that is
on a pedestal if you don't like it it's
undeniable I would disagree I would I it
is undeniable what it did but I would
disagree I would say the only other show
that did that is friend dude
was a hit song like that's crazy yeah
it's crazy like when you hear that song
you get like emotional it makes you
think dude that show I will tell you
this I'll tell you that you know what
both shows have done this for me both
shows have done this for me honestly but
more so
even in the shorter amount of time I
spent with friends I can say more so
with friends
it has made me think of you and my and
like our friendship sure I like watch it
and I watch everybody hanging out in
Monica's apartment and I'm like
oh that's like when I hang out at sounds
and we're all there and you know what I
mean like honestly you're like oh I'm
like Monaco we hang out at South I am
like Monica very particular I'm money
we're two monikers I got news for you
I'm a loss I'm Ross for sure but that's
what people did a lot with that I'm this
I'm that I really don't know yeah but
people do that to me bro people are like
I'm like you I'm like okay with Seinfeld
because I'm I'm a Costanza with a little
Cramer sprinkled in yeah I think I'm po
I'm part all of them and that's the
beauty of that one too that's a good
point I'm part of all that but I uh but
I will say like um with Seinfeld
this is how much of a Monica I am uh I
will say this I've seen every episode of
every episode yeah I've seen minimum
minimum five times these episodes I've
probably seen 30 times so what is can I
ask you a question my point is can I ask
you a question if something is that
repeatable sure how can how can
something be that repeatable I you I get
sick of hearing songs I got sick of too
many Lucky Charms I get sick of [__] how
could I watch the same Seinfeld episode
and just smile and say the words along
with it can I ask you a question yeah
what is what is wrong in your head
you texted me last night you just said
you've seen every episode five times
and you're not sick of it you texted me
last night and said I don't know if I
feel prepared to defend Seinfeld
properly how much more prepared could
you I'll tell you why I said that I'll
tell you why I said that okay I I
have not watched Seinfeld in a while and
I used to be able to it was like a
freakish knowledge and I I just wished I
could come to the table with my freakish
knowledge now it's just like it's a deep
knowledge but and then I thought of it
for one second and I literally the next
text I was like now what am I saying I
could do that right you know what I mean
right um the uh this is how much of a
Monica I am right
yeah I was watching an episode recently
where she she can't get over that she
broke up with Tom Selleck turn that
thing off yeah I'm just worried about
the prince we got v on it visa on it
okay this guy's not a king he's just a
Prince Let's cool our Jets
I'm so excited he's I can't believe I'm
gonna be principal today I'm I can't
wrap my head around this right now
anyway I mean I think he knows what he's
getting into and then we'll be screaming
at him over matzo ball or something
we should maybe do a hip-hop battle with
him
I know we've teased these we can do
these another time
anyway
uh it was she can't get over that the
Tom Selleck break up
and she starts making JoJo crying she's
no I won't she starts making jam and
she's like this I need something to do
and then she's like you know what the
jam thing it's not working because it's
gonna cost me 70 a jar to break even or
whatever
and uh and I was like that's kind of
like my Hoagie store like her Jam
business like my hoagie shop and then
she comes in and the next scene and she
goes I'm done with the jam and she's
like I'm gonna have a baby I know it's
not the idea and everybody's like have
you thought of it and I was like I am so
Monica this is so me talking to Sal
right now about I want to buy a house in
the Poconos and he's like Joe have you
thought about this yeah calm down for
sure
sure I I um I will say she graded on me
sometimes
uh Cox that's a little waspy I will say
this there's nothing whiter on planet
Earth than friends there's I don't think
they had maybe Mumford and Sons yeah I
don't think well they've caught Flack
for that and they they but I mean
Seinfeld was all white cast too but they
did have side to lean heavy though into
at least white diversity they get into
Jewish they get into Italians yeah you
know they had they had many black uh and
there are black uh characters yeah but
yeah but Seinfeld the best of all black
characters on Cyber was Rebecca De
Mornay it's oh yeah
because you know they did this anyway
with Donna Chang remember Donna Chang
yes Donna Chang's a great one too yeah
and she was supposed to be like I think
you like people thinking you're Chinese
the uh yeah that's a great episode it
was that Chinese woman she's like it's
me Donna Chang
[Laughter]
um but okay with Seinfeld I also I like
that I like
a uh it's not cereal I like that I kind
of like it it's it's like its own things
get wrapped up in the episode I I like
that uh they they did they did it well
when they hit that chart when they
didn't intend to but they ended up
hitting that shy where the B storyline
and the a storyline comes together at
the end and it didn't feel forced that's
something that's what that's what Larry
doesn't curb now he's he's the master of
it yes she is I mean look there'd be no
curb without Seinfeld I know that and
curb is probably my one of my favorite
shows of all time if not there's nobody
on television I have ever related more
to than Larry David right I mean ever in
my life right I I and I I know everybody
feels like that but people
and I'm telling you
I it's a TR I have a true relation to
this to that character right like I'm
just like I've seen so many things where
I'm like I've done that yeah I've come
I'm saying started something over this
exact thing whatever but but um
uh but oh but Seinfeld they did do that
for a while and then in season season
seven to me is where Seinfeld starts to
taper off I did not like that they did a
whole season about George now the finale
of the season of George getting married
a few times they did it yeah is great
that she dies that they went there it's
it's so crazy it's amazing I mean but I
sitcom where the main character
it like literally his his wife dies I'll
say this was she his wife Susan yes yes
fiance right right my fiancee I'll say
this though I've lost it my my fiance
has an inner ear infection yeah I'll say
this though I think friends does
arguably edgier jokes than Seinfeld
there's you know Phoebe going like
Phoebe going like my mom always let me
touch the end of old yellow liquor [__]
it was too dark you know before she
killed herself like I'm like suicide
well they had they had a whole show
about masturbation but yeah you're I I
could see that there's some dark jokes
they joke about like abuse like
emotional abuse yeah I love that they go
in on my like Monica used to be fat and
they just make fun of it no they do some
things right I I will it's great it's
great but I'll tell you another thing
there was a point in friends where I was
like I was like almost like enough
already like they now this one's dating
this one and they have a pass this one's
in this one and then they got so caught
up in the middle of their all of their
relationships so then it became a show
about six people's relationships she and
and they were all individuals and I'm
like this is more like it's funny
they're peppering in jokes but it's now
like it's so much leaning in on the back
and forth of relationships and being
heartbroken and you know and and all
that stuff and it's like
I came away from Seinfeld for the most
part every episode just it's water
cooler it's like you talk about it and I
will say this I know I just said this
but honestly it's not 10 phrases it's
not 50 phrases it's not even a hundred
phrases there are phrases that exist
solely because of Seinfeld and I mean
you're talking about hundreds of
references I think it's about a hundred
178 episodes ish there's sometimes
there's a couple a couple of them
perhaps I don't think but you're saying
public Man Hands you're close talker
[__] everything you really counted it
up it's about maybe 50 at the most
that's my opinion but maybe references
but also just terms that be like not not
like new references but just the way
like there had to be a second spinner
anything and everything you say this
I'll say this I'll say this I do not I
do not care for the fact that Joey and
uh Rachel start the full oh you know
that yeah I told you I know a lot of you
didn't say that earlier I didn't say
everything I didn't love that I didn't
love it I don't like it it's just sad I
don't I don't care for it but
uh oh wait here's the the point I've
been hoping to get to and after a while
I want to talk about you want to talk
about a Powerhouse
this [__] show launched six people
who like six award-winning people like
this is That's crazy dude that's great
Seinfeld did four of them
I mean everything was only up and up
until until
I love the cast of Seinfeld yeah Michael
Richards had a hard time finding work
afterwards Jason and Alexander had a
hard time afterwards yeah but Julia
that's because their characters were so
like that's fine forget about it doesn't
matter Julian dress was bad a thousand
at all times even Seinfeld himself like
the other Venture B movie these other
things you know you're like all right
I'm not knocking them
immense respect for these people I would
be honored to meet and speak with any of
them but you can't it's no contest when
it comes to friends launch dude
Schwimmer like theater chops out his ass
indie film uh dramatic television uh
Aniston of course movie star Kudrow uh
amazing actor The Comeback uh she
creates and produces television uh an
amazing actor Cox uh uh Cox with the
what was the MILF show she did
Cougar Town spraying all that stuff
Matthew Perry if it wasn't for his
I feel bad for him with his addiction
issues if it wasn't for that [__]
getting his way this guy's like one of
the greatest comedic actors in recent
decades LeBlanc went on does tooting
last man stand or not no I'm sorry uh he
did that show on Showtime or something
like that he did he did
Joey bombed but then he went and did the
second show they created called it's not
extras it's called episodes and then
after episodes he had he had he had the
sitcom that was a hit a man of the house
wherever the phone
um is that is
named right okay did I just name
everybody
yeah Dan you want to talk about launch
and talent Giovanni Ribisi coming in he
was that was a guest star he already was
who he was dude he's like 17 on this
thing no he's not no he's not dude he
had work before that for show for show I
don't know he was probably in boiler
room before that
now Boiler Room is like 2001 dude
but you mentioned that there by the way
the theme song very ubiquitous team so
you mentioned I'll tell you right now
that's that whole 90s Lilith Fair type
of [__] and it's it's it's funny is all
women little Affairs yeah but it's like
that that that that that uh and I say
what about breakfast
it was a huge hit it was a huge hit I
mean jealousy wait no but that stuff
when's the last time it's very 90s
friends could be the last when I say
this yeah and I think you're going to
agree with thee friends could be the
last
sitcom In Our Lifetime that had a theme
song that could go on to a sitcom theme
songs CD I don't want I haven't watched
a sitcom in 20 years but my point is
it's it's I know I know the theme from
King of Queens but it's not it's not one
that everybody but sometimes it's also
like sometimes you you want to go
you get Darren in are you like oh
[__] shut the [__] song up please
I'll tell you this Seinfeld look at what
that theme song There is no [__]
theme song the guy slapping the bass and
that's it it's it sometimes it's five
seconds sometimes it's ten seconds it's
always good you could hit two notes and
you're like that's Seinfeld Seinfeld's
easier to fall asleep to because it
doesn't have the theme song at the
beginning of every episode
even curb is hard to fall asleep to
because because every episode every
episode occur
like that'll you're like whoa what
happened you know if you doze off but
Seinfeld's the only one that used their
theme song in the transitions of the
show as well it it's it's woven into the
fabric of the show in a way that other
shows don't do friends does like little
variations of the theme throughout not
from scene to scenes for Segways
sometimes they do and at the end they'll
put a thing
I'm telling you I don't know they just
all right well did it first they'll like
sometimes take a variation of that main
riff and use it like at the very end of
the episode or like in between a scene
you want to say that it launch those
Stars Seinfeld was the first sitcom for
the stars to make a million an episode
for the 22 Episodes of the Season no
friends was wasn't it Seinfeld was okay
and then friends was I think I'm near
positive I don't know and they paved the
way I mean you talk about them being I
mean you know it's always like it's like
sports someone has to break the ceiling
and then that's the new precedent and
then someone else and I think Seinfeld
did it and then friends was the second
people to do it right I know that
um Jennifer Anderson was getting paid
the most and then she said no I heard I
heard they they they said that happened
they like came all together she's like
I'm not going to be paid the most on
this and so like everybody else uh like
they came together
I will say that too by the way I will
say that and it goes a long way for a
guy like me and you and it was very
evident on the Friends reunion that they
did on HBO
they truly seem to care about each other
in real life it seems like there's a
true camaraderie there I'm sorry dude I
don't get that at all from Seinfeld you
watch like the the Charlie Rose
Roundtable things with Seinfeld they're
all business like they're like they
don't seem like they're connected anyway
you watch the outtakes Michael Richards
isn't laughing he's getting like annoyed
with them yeah he was serious about that
[__] Larry David and Jerry clearly had
some kind of like you know what I mean
yes and and so even when they come back
together on so you're saying there's a
chemistry and friends that was more
authentic yes and when they come back
when they come back together on that
reunion and they're walking around the
set it's like I didn't even watch the
show at that point I was like this is
really sweet this is really endearing
like they love each other like there's a
real okay that's a really nice thing but
the comedic chemistry they had it on
Seinfeld I mean I don't give a [__]
great comedian chemistry on Seinfeld but
but but I
I can't knock a show for not having good
off-screen relations right but that's
what you were doing
you just did it and then you said you
can't do it I gotta pee so do I I don't
know why I just said that like Trump I
don't know I gotta pee yeah
I don't do a trump impression everyone
does a trump impression it looks like
such fun to do I know I don't know how
to do it
it does look really fun
I don't know how to I don't do
Impressions do you do any Impressions
any at all even close anything at all
yeah I have a I have a Tom Hanks I've
done it on here haven't I I don't know I
don't recall I used to do Tom Hanks
I used to do a thing in my ACT I would
do voiceless Impressions it was just
like body language body like mannerism
sure sure so Tom Hanks was one
oh so you don't okay so okay so go ahead
yeah we do Tom Hanks and angrily
agreeing with somebody okay yeah yeah
say like ask a question that somebody
would ask a Tom Hanks character in a
movie okay think of a plot line go so
you mean to tell me you know right right
uh I think of a movie it has to be a
comedy then okay ready
uh I'm sorry to tell you but this this
house is basically a money pit
[Laughter]
[Music]
every movie I I think I see them he
would get like Furious
because they're in the it's the birds
yeah it always people always got it yeah
I did Clooney
I forget how I did I would like I'd be
like there was always the part in the
argument where he's like he's like
coming on to the woman but he's
intimidating her yeah
I did Michael J fox and Teen Wolf
walking down the hallway
uh how'd you do that one the one when
you won't get it on you when he is Teen
Wolf
no okay
I forget that I wish you could remember
the Clooney what the setup because the
Clooney always Gotta Laugh
which surprised me but I can't remember
what the setup for it was
all right ready maybe another time
wow
what okay
okay that was like his I saw I saw him
in that I saw him in in you just now
yeah yeah uh great guy I told you I had
lunch with him yes what a surreal lunch
that was yeah Q told me like the story
in depth over a lunch that we were
having yeah and I said I hope that you
now go back to Michael J fox and tell
him about this lunch yeah
I think that I I don't know he was he's
an icon to think I sat down and had
lunch yeah it's amazing a couple few
hours went back to his office hunting
about sitcoms watching careers Jesus
Christ yeah yeah
um all right let's go
and I've had to pee for the whole time
and so I think that might have clouded
because I have a lot more to say about
Seinfeld I could keep going on this yeah
uh but let's let's just get the vote
pimp
okay what were the best like supporting
characters V you're killing me I gotta
pee I mean you can throw any celebrity
you want at me from friends as far as a
good support you mean you mean like a
like but like not like a regular some
regular to semi from semi regulating to
semi-regular to one-offs Seinfeld I
don't care that you bring on Brad Pitt
Paul Rudd whoever you Seinfeld did it
without people being Stars they did it
from the writing and from the characters
that's another thing how many what other
sitcom can you name that everyone
everyone can name every single one-off
character Friends one-off character I'm
not talking about the guy from the
[__] coffee shop
one-offs David David Arquette you know
recurring no he wasn't he's in one
episode as as as oh my God I forgot that
too the awesome connection about you
where they get Phoebe to be twins with
the waitress she played on man but
anyway way everybody can name the one
off characters
you have to name you just named the
celebrity David Arquette but I'm saying
Oh The Soup Nazi oh you know like these
types of characters are iconic and
they're one episode characters are you
kidding me well I can't just named it
before Donna chicken I can't well but
hold on everybody everybody it's an
unfair art not even Uncle Leo I'm
talking about the one-offs it's an
unfair argument here's why why
it's an uneven argument because friends
given the nature of the show called for
recurring characters Seinfeld called for
one-off cat characters sure but that is
the nature of the show and that's one of
its Pro what's one of its cool sure I
could also say well friends was better
at bringing in a recurring guy over
three episodes for an arc that was
really interesting you know what's his
face that plays the crazy roommate that
Chandler gets is so awesome
uh uh the Indie actor the kid that was
in Saving Private Ryan
um no no no no the kid from the place
you could honestly if I sat down and had
some time I could make a list of
I mean a hundred a hundred characters
that were famous Adam Goldberg what show
had better jokes to you made you
actually laugh out loud more I gotta
tell you I think I think pound for pound
friend has friends has better jokes I
think Seinfeld as you form a
relationship with the show it becomes
funny what is that
it becomes funny in its own way because
you need to be familiar with the show
but there is a lot of stuff on Seinfeld
where you're like they're they're
resting on your fandom right now I was
going to say the options there is stuff
there's stuff on paper that's not even
close to a joke that they plug a laugh
into and you go because I because of it
there's a rhythm to Seinfeld there's a
familiarity that works and it makes me
laugh but it's a seinfeld-ism thing it's
not a joke joke
friends has like joke jokes where I'm
like holy [__] yeah like that's a that's
a setup yeah but you're writing the
jokes are different I mean you're
writing two different types of jokes and
I think both of them did their own thing
well but I don't think you can compare
that they're better than Seinfeld
because
I'm talking joke jokes I think friends
his friends is situationally like
friends has like more natural speaking
dialogue type of jokes but Seinfeld has
way more like punch lines and way more
like like nuance and just situationally
funny things I think uh I don't know if
I agree with that but uh but that's
interesting well think about this right
for Seinfeld you could say that the
premise of an episode was funny a lot of
times and that's without hearing a joke
you could be like oh my God that was so
funny when they got lost in the parking
garage oh my god when they made the bed
about masturbation oh my god when you
know whatever yeah they're coming at it
from a different angle I mean if you're
just a person but but think of it like
stand up right even the premises were
funny oh my God he left a message on
their machine he wants to get back oh my
God he pees in the shower George talks
to the third person this is like saying
that to me though is like saying well
then
you know you're not like oh my God I
could argue that people filled out a job
at the bakery and then she started
dating but my point is I could argue
that emo Phillips has by the sound of it
funnier premises than big J but I don't
think that makes emo a better comic than
Jay Jay talks about more real life
things I can relate to you know what I
mean so like that doesn't make the
premise well you said that doesn't you
said that jokes were better and I'm just
saying that like I I would say that big
Jay's jokes are better than emo Phillips
without disrespect big J is friends in
this scenario okay uh I I actually am
relatable a lot of sex material
but I will say but I will say though
think about another sitcom where you
could be like oh people are latching on
to the idea of them people name episodes
by the premise
yourself you're stepping in the wrong
territory or With Friends the episodes
are literally called the one with sure
that's every episode sure sure but a lot
of times you I mean you can't you can't
go into the Rolodex I mean you can say
something like oh the Thanksgiving you
know the Thanksgiving football game or
like the time they went on the the dance
party show which you didn't say I don't
I don't agree Seinfeld is more like
I'm telling you man it's like oh she
wore the same outfit it's like this it's
just people related to Seinfeld I in a
weird way even though friends is more
based in reality and not this own
Universe Seinfeld created a universe
that was
I think even more relatable than friends
I think because it was about behavioral
yeah but it wasn't just the same old
thing like oh I'm dating her oh my you
know but if it's I got a promotion but
hold on it's for I don't think friends
is the same old thing I think France has
a different goal
then Seinfeld it was going the the pitch
the pitch the the log line for the show
is it's about the time of your life when
your friends or family it's just a
different Show You could argue all day
long of course that Seinfeld is a little
more offbeat a little more original
because it I can't argue any of that of
course it's certainly more that's more
relatable it's just it's not more
related how is it not more relatable if
people literally describe themselves in
Seinfeld characters people have
conversations using Seinfeld speaks
because people people literally
have monikers that's not what relatable
is sure it is quoting something quoting
something because you think it's funny
it's not related that's not true though
it they they they deal in behavioral
nuances and that is relatable to every
single every single person watch someone
not wash their hands after they pissed
every single person got cut in line at
the whatever and they dig into that and
not just like oh I love him all right
and I'm an artist every single person
dated somebody multiple times and dumped
them multiple times every single person
was in love with a friend of theirs that
they couldn't be with every single
person
it didn't work out but this is so much
more original Seinfeld but I it is it's
a universe in and of itself it's it's
it's an yes I'm not saying it's not a
more original take on a sitcom that was
the whole point of Seinfeld was we're
not we're going to do an unsitcom or
whatever I get that you know Sunny is
based on Seinfeld
uh yeah they've come right out and said
that yes uh but uh they use the Seinfeld
rules no redeeming qualities nothing no
one falls in love they're all for
themselves Dave Dave I love Sonny
they've started to betray that stuff but
my point is is
I mean Dennis is a full-blown sociopath
now it's like I love the show but it's
like you know come on they did it they
ended an episode with a full
interpretive dance and it wasn't a joke
yeah
yeah like yeah but I mean I like that
that they did that I thought it was
pretty you know you want to talk about
friends being sometimes sobering if
Seinfeld had done some I'm not there for
that that's not what I'm watching this
show for I hated I hate it again on the
Seinfeld finale the the moment with
Elaine and him on the plane I hated that
the lead into that played that [__]
Green Day song uh where they showed
clips and you were supposed to get all
Misty about it I was like this is
Seinfeld that's not what this is that's
not what I'm here for I disagree man I
think it's I think you said that that's
what you liked about it was that it's
not that you said you didn't like that
they reflected and played the song about
all the moments and I disagree I watched
Seinfeld through and through and that
last thing was like watching the Super
Bowl it was so in establishable all the
characters no no you're not you're
talking about the Highlight Reel you're
talking I don't like that they played
the time of my life Green Day song and
tried to get you emotional but it worked
but it's not it's Seinfeld it's not
supposed to do it but in the moment it
worked I
I don't want to see an interpretive
dancer that's always sunny I'm sorry I
will tell you I hate that green day so
I'm more than I hate the friends and and
and
just like and by the way just like on
Fringe if they brought in like a Kramer
I'd be like this is stupid like this
doesn't fit in the into this thing you
know what I mean like there's things
that both shows do very very well I mean
you want to take I mean Phoebe is she's
offbeat but like really they they they
have you know characteristics like uh
Monica's type a uh Ross's you know type
whatever we want to go but like to
create a a character like Kramer but
hold on I did not I'm not you're you're
you're I'm just saying as far as the
characters go
like dig everyone loves the friends
people but they are just they're not
just
they're complete they have very normal
characteristics I'm saying I felt
created I think it's a lot I think it's
a lot harder to pull that off than
you're giving a credit for I've watched
a lot of sitcoms and I've written for a
pretty good amount of TV shows at this
point that is such a hard thing to do
within the confines of a 22-minute
script what create real characters it's
not like oh Monica is just this or that
becomes so paper thin so quickly yeah
but you're saying real characters and
I'm saying unique original one-of-a-kind
characters like you know what I mean
like I think Kramer I I think if you
think of sitcoms the history of sitcoms
and you have to have a bracket
Tournament of the quirkiest craziest or
characters like Kramer's going in there
I think Phoebe gives Kramer a run for
her money you know who's not going in
there Jerry Elaine I mean it doesn't get
any more like regular old shikami than
those two characters they're great
they're [__] great because the two
actors portraying them are great but
it's the same thing George Costanza you
could compare to a million sitcom
characters that came before him oh he's
the hot head that yells all the time and
freaks out about nothing
oh I saw it with Archie Bunker you know
what I mean like it's like you you it
doesn't matter it's I think on either of
these shows to try to reduce the
characters to do it's just X Y and Z on
paper you could say Kramer dude Kramer
on paper
is just a zany neighbor
on paper it's almost cringy it's what
Michael Richards does with it that makes
its great sure so I so I I'm just
countering the the argument of the
Friends character it's like on on paper
Chandler is annoying he's the quippy guy
Matthew Perry they talk about it in the
reunion special like how hard it was to
cast that show because this they and
they talked about it with like uh
Jennifer S and they're like this we
Rachel is not likable she's not a
likable person so we had to get somebody
that could make her life that that stuff
is a lot more complicated than I think
people give a credit for all right well
anyway let's go to the [__] phones
because we gotta do I gotta pee so bad I
got a piece so bad let's get the vote
percentages all right this is going to
be how many how many votes ten thousand
that's it so far I thought people would
jump on that because the nature of it oh
10 000 in an hour is not bad all right
the winner with 56 oh that's close bro
very close that's very close Seinfeld
56 though that is that is very close
very close be close great wow that was
that was very close I yep you still I
don't think anyone would I still love
you I love you too
okay
taste buds they coming to the mic
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them